Wednesday basically final push here for
the release.
We have a couple small things to do on
the articles. Very small.
We have some small fixes to make.
We have a few more environments to port
I think we do some environment stuff now
and then maybe docks.
right.
What we need here
MOA
drive terraform impulse first.
Definitely need moa and terraform.
Hello programmers. Well, what does
amazing
apply for remote?
I don't know. Where are you interested
in working and how skilled are you?
Right.
I I think at the moment like very
skilled people it's either you start
your own thing, you join a very small
exciting startup or you start your own.
These days
I can't really speak to other stuff.
I don't know like places that are just
This is kind of not the thing I do, man.
Like
I don't really do job advice.
I can teach people how to learn this
stuff, but
I'm not really the type to um
I have not been to a lot of companies
and I don't really plan on being at um a
bunch of companies,
you know.
[ __ ]
No, I have enough that I'm not too
worried about the day-to-day stuff and I
can kind of just build um I can build on
my stuff for a while. And Popper is
profitable, so I don't really have to
worry about that either. And it's
growing quite nicely as well.
No investors to worry about.
I think I probably just have very
different priorities in life, right?
I want to absolutely steamroll this area
of science so that it can be broadly
used everywhere and advance a number of
different technologies. I want to have
my own little company, my own little
lab. I've been running here making those
breakthroughs without a whole bunch of
other [ __ ] to be spending my time
on.
And that's what I've been doing.
Not that much. Not that that much else
really matters.
fundraising.
I'm not raising funds. That's the thing.
I just have clients with Puffer.
I know it's a company. We build high
performance simulations for um a few
different companies.
Not every business needs to raise funds,
you know, if it doesn't cost you a lot
of money to run your business and you
can sell something or provide services
that you can charge for. It's actually
funny. It's how most businesses work.
Now, I would look for, if I were you,
I'd probably look for any of the
companies that are growing very, very
quickly and that are trying to hire very
fast.
That would probably be my suggestion if
you just want to get something,
you know, any of the new companies that
just raised like a billion dollars and
they're trying to hire a thousand people
in a couple of months.
trading on Google Cloud
hustle though.
I mean, if you have a long enough like
um work history like that, then you
shouldn't have a problem just finding
something, right?
The big companies, it's a little bit
more annoying. A lot of them are
reference based and stuff, but
any of the ones that are growing quickly
are just trying to find anybody who
seems competent.
Again, this is not I'm not really the
person to ask about this because this is
not really what I do.
I kind of just um
I work on my tooling. I work on resource
uh research
and I sort of ignore a lot of the
happenings
outside of that as much as I can.
more. I mean, it's more so I've just
been doing research for the last 15
years and like half of my life really.
And I'm in a position here where I have
a branch of AI that I can really really
just flip on its head overnight. And
I've been doing that. It's been going
incredibly well. We have some reasonable
applications that are marketable and the
general tech advancement is very
exciting.
That's mostly what I focus on.
3.7 steps million steps I suppose
study much yeah I mean this is just
release work I'm doing for the time
being like the release is very soon.
star. Anything else?
I mean, we have a lot of open source
work, but it's probably not going to
help a ton with the type of jobs that
you're looking for. Um,
we don't really do a lot of enterprisey
stuff, right? It's a lot of just
low-level,
really concise, tight, high performance
code.
voting friends I can help.
Well, Discord's uh discord.gg/puffer.
That's where we run all the open source
from. This entire project is open source
and we have lots of guides on getting
into reinforcement learning and stuff.
It's mainly just the people that uh
stick around end up getting quite good
that put in the work.
This is very very odd right now. Hang
on.
Uh
this makes sense.
and we got quite a nice community there.
Got all sorts of fun demos and cool tech
on the website.
Now there's a g there's there is some
sense to it.
I guess we just have to render this,
don't we?
very weird.
Hey S,
how's it going?
Got very weird stuff happening here.
Do you have a warehouse as your office?
Yes.
And does the gym?
Thank you for reminding me.
Got a bench.
Well, I've been quite lazy with my
training lately,
but uh
having every day be bench day actually
does work, it seems.
Two plates for eight.
Yeah, we got to fix the toilet time
steps thingy.
It's very jumpy though.
I wouldn't be surprised if it's wrong.
Zuck fight today.
You can just start it on that fight. I
guarantee you it can solve that one
fight, right? If it doesn't, there's
something wrong.
that. go look and then we will go check
ourselves.
Hey, vault. Did you know that magic XP
is 100 100k an hour completely AFK on a
pure
Go see if I can figure this out.
Ow.
Nightmare.
This nice
arm staff was a huge upgrade
without even pages.
That's a major book. 100k an hour.
He boosted
frost crabs.
What the hell are those, dude?
Huh.
Interesting. They only have 60 health
though.
You'd need like freaking eight of them
in a spawn.
This is actually XP reduced, but you
know, it's you don't overkill.
And I got lucky. So, this would have
been way slower and I would have had to
do this in splash gear, but it turns out
I have two hit points levels before 79.
So, this is actually going to be done at
level 78
with 96 hit points.
78 combat, 99 what will be 99 strength,
magic, range, 50 attack.
Nightmare.
Hey, Liberty.
Now, Nightmare Zone's worse for magic. I
tried it. I did that for ranged with
venadator bow. That was also 100k.
Strength was awful. Strength was 60k an
hour.
It's going to be really cool like
debugging um the inferno and with
somebody who actually understands the
game as well
cuz there's so much stuff with this game
that you don't like you don't really see
unless you really know the mechanics of
it, right?
work as hard on some of the hit. I
didn't see the colo run.
You could do colo next. I actually think
inferno is better for um this envi like
it's inferno is a better test
environment cuz it's like a longer
challenge. It'll give us more room to
test out the 5 like state set stuff.
Ko was also just like not that hard. I
think Ko took me maybe 12 total hours of
learning it to get the cape,
maybe 15
without protection prayers. That's
pretty awesome.
Can you do that?
He brought sweets and I'd imagine you
can bring sweets into Ko, can't you?
Which is why you can't do that with
Inferno.
You started with that as opposed to You
think?
Yeah, I get I mean the waves are harder
I guess, but like the fact that it takes
a freaking hour to get back to the um
the main part of it and the fact that
you lose so much money in Inferno where
you actually like make money uh in some
of the KO runs
or at least break even a lot of the
time.
I ended up getting um
I got the freaking crystal in both of
the fanatic pieces, the top and the
legs. Just learning it.
You can't bring sweets.
Jeez, that's nuts. All right. I thought
you could bring sweets. That's crazy
then.
Yeah, that's nuts.
Well, I see why the obs are messed up
here.
That's actually crazy to think about
without sweets. Like that's nuts.
I mean, that's cool though, right?
because that basically tells us like
there's a ton of stuff we could
potentially
train the agent on. Like there are a ton
of um self-imposed challenges
that we could like we could Bye.
I'm trying to think what I would have
messed up with this, you know.
It could literally just be the ops to be
There.
I guess we could
Hang on.
see about this. It could just be that we
have really screwy values here.
Oh, wait. Is this
This is sort of something.
I wouldn't be surprised if we could do
this with neural MMO.
It might just be data norms.
Let's see if this actually like does the
thing though. Episode length is 4K.
That looks reasonable. If this is not
it, then it's going to be like something
very bugged.
Is it glitched into the wall or is this
the render? I think this is just the old
render bug.
How is it supposed to be winning this
again?
Interestingly, these ones don't get any
XP.
Oh, no. They do. They just get really
shitty XP.
I don't see how it's showing this 100%
victory. Then
This needs to definitely be cleaned up
and like fixed.
It's like the same thing as the way that
the Open AI5 uh paper does it basically.
right, let's see if this actually works.
I don't think it does.
Oh, wait. That actually could be it,
right?
They got the level eight tank
rushing them.
I don't understand.
They just fed the level eight. They just
fed the tank all the levels and now he's
going to end the freaking game, isn't
he?
Now we have instant one.
I wonder if this is actually legit now.
See what the hell this is.
He's 16k up length.
I see.
I'll do it.
Oh, this looks like it's doing
something.
It's actually funny. So, this has a
level advantage, but it's not destroying
towers.
Well, I mean this is something here,
right? That like
it is leveling.
I trust this result way more.
Hey Jess, I am cleaning up different
environments so that we can actually use
them for benchmarks.
This is mobile.
It's like a miniature Dota.
If I bring old techies into the mobile
and will you merge the PR
if you actually clean up this
environment and like either make
selfplay work correctly or give it like
actually reasonable script opponents to
play against and get a decent baseline
in four that's fast. You can add techis
to it as well. Sure.
You can do whatever as long as we get a
cool environment and a cool baseline.
The code is not that bad either. It's
like it's pretty decent overall.
Could Puffer defeated Open A5? No, it's
not really comparable. Um, we definitely
have tech now that would have been
useful in that project, but ultimately
you still get bottlenecked by the end of
being super slow. Like they needed
50,000 cores to run the ends and even
then they really weren't getting that
much data. Like they were basically
running
they were running all that hardware to
get about as much data as we can get
from one GPU one puffer.
There's a motivation. Yeah. I mean it's
a great way to learn stuff. It's a great
way to get into some RL. Um
we do want people to help with this
stuff as well. That'd be awesome. It's
starting to get some wins here as well.
I think this is no longer screwed. I
think this is actually like real wins,
not cheating.
Pester Spencer. Well, once we have
selfplay, we'll do it for everything.
It's just kind of hard to figure out how
to do it nicely.
That's cool.
Whatever that is.
Not interested. Why don't I get to like
not interested?
Stupid man.
Um, is this actually going to do real
win rate?
It's like thinking about it.
No, we have it's a full render. I'll
show you after this trains.
There's a full render for this.
It's uh it's human playable as well. You
can like play the game.
There probably some bugs, but
it's not bad.
you can clean up your timeline.
So,
it's kind of tough. I've done it before,
but the algorithm is so sensitive. Like,
didn't they add a thing where you can do
that? Like, where you can just set the
topics or whatever?
There's really not that much on here
that is even like that even matters.
they become low quality suggest. Yeah,
that probably works.
Hey, we're training the moa environment
with a really dumb policy right now.
This number is going to go up like 20x
in a moment as well. I just just there's
a dumb um
the threading was different so it wasn't
thread safe in the new version which is
why it wasn't training
I like the big red X button in the
corner of the browser to mute. That's
the best one.
How are you rendering Rayb? It's the
same moa that we have, man. We've had
this for ages. It was one of the first
projects I did. You know, this MOA you
can like take over if you just hold
shift. This is now me playing it.
I think it works with like blink strike
and stuff, right?
Why does my blink strike not go off?
I thought this is the character that has
the blink strike. I don't remember.
I know the speed boost on this thing
works.
Yeah. So, it has the speed boost.
Oh, yeah. There it goes. That's the
blink strike. It was the wrong button.
And then you can like go to the
different characters.
And there five different ones.
Renders knobs. Hell no, man. Local
state.
Hell no.
There's a puffer fish.
Well, this gets 20% win rate
with the really [ __ ] policy.
All I need is positive win rate to start
a sweep.
You mult mentioned multi-agent RL is
effectively the same as single agent RL.
Yeah, that's still the same there. Nerd
sniping Jess
selfplay is different. Like competitive
selfplay is different, but it's not
really because of the multi- aent. Like
you can replicate that with other things
that aren't multi- aent if you try.
You'd have to be nuts to use the render
as knobs.
It's so much slower.
Puffer can be way way way faster now
without that stuff.
Almost done. We'll visit this and we'll
see if we fix the bug. We'll do a
training run with threading on. It'll be
way faster. We'll see if we get the same
result.
Also, I hear you've been slacking off
and playing deadlock.
Okay, that's actually like at least a
reasonable rush mid type policy, right?
It's farming a little bit. I think he
gets stuck on the walls though.
You got a couple of them rushing though.
For 20% win rate, this is reasonable.
Need to stop. See, this is why I've got
this thing which just sits on the other
monitor.
Pass the fireball. Just sit on the
monitor. You get maximum magic.
How do I join the convo on Discord?
The convo?
I mean, you want to jump in voice on
Discord, I can do that.
Okay. Didn't want to do the Wait, what
chat stream?
There isn't a chat stream for Discord,
my guy. There's It's XY YouTube or
Twitch.
Latency is probably better on YouTube or
Why is this all of a sudden way better?
That's sketchy to me.
Runescape solved AGI.
Um, honestly,
honestly, Runescape is going to be the
end for um a lot of research.
like
the RSM if that's done well will just be
so incredible for research.
I don't think people understand like
what that's going to enable.
It has to be implemented well to be
useful, but as long as we have it good,
like
holy, that'll be nice. All right. Do we
have anybody stuck looking like they
can't path correctly?
No, they look like they path.
I think it's bug fixed, right?
I guess we just try it and we see,
right?
RS cast fireballs.
It's a great end too. Yeah,
it's it's funny, but it'll actually be a
really good environment, especially for
what I have in mind for 5. It'll be
really nice for testing.
chatting from Twitch watching on
YouTube. Mod modern software sucks. I
mean,
we could probably fix that if we wanted
to, but I got better [ __ ] to do.
And now
okay.
Um
How do you like the new uh the new 40
workflow?
There's still some bugs. There's still
some small things I'm fixing. Um they're
not that hard to work around if you know
the library cuz like they're quick
fixes. I keep breaking little things
here and there, but the speed is
definitely there. I'm hoping
I should do terraform
learning how to cuda graph
m that render worlds are pretty generic.
Wait,
if your whole env is like one CUDA
kernel, you wouldn't need to graph it,
right?
Graphing is for when you have a bunch of
CUDA kernels.
It's actually way less needed now, by
the way. Like you can train 10 mil plus
steps per second without uh cudigraphs
since we fused everything. But it used
to be before we fused everything, it
would be like 4 mil SPS not graft and
then 15 mil graft. The difference would
be way bigger.
The fewer little operations you have,
the less cudigraphing matters. And
cudigraphing is a pain in the ass. Um,
it definitely is a pain in the ass.
Get up for
I'm feeling terraform. What do you
think?
more refreshed. I'm actually not Jess.
I'm like I feel okay, but mentally I'm
just gone.
So, I've got energy to see this release
through, but just like
I got nothing else to do. I have nothing
else for real thinking at the moment.
I have at least been getting some
exercise in like really light shitty 5k
in the morning.
Bench has been good. I need to do more
though.
Just need to like not for a bit, you
know.
I'm going to try to get everything done
so we can just release this damn thing
on Monday and then I got to take a day
trip to York
for a thing.
streams
for what?
You know, we have every buffer is on a
different food stream for our rollouts.
modularize the same engine.
Don't modularize [ __ ] you're do. You
have one freaking environment, dude.
Don't overbuild the crap out of it.
a fast Minecraft clone be a beneficial
end?
Um,
Jess, it would be a beneficial end in
the sense that everybody goes nuts over
Minecraft cuz it's Minecraft.
I don't actually think it's that good of
an environment.
like Runescape is way freaking better.
Um, Net Hack that people can actually
understand what's going on is way
better.
Well, that thing is should probably just
be a function,
right?
I don't know. You do you do the very
simplest little thing you possibly can
to make it freaking general.
Yeah. But don't don't build it in case
it gets swapped out, right? Change it
when you need to swap stuff.
What makes a good an um
there are a lot of different types of
good environments, Jess. Like it could
just be something simple that lets us
test something that we would obviously
want to test like memory or like uh you
know continuous actions or like high dim
or whatever.
So there's a lot of simple stuff that's
useful. M that scale really well are
nice where like you can solve a simple
version of it quickly, but there's a
complex version that goes on and on.
2048's really good at that. Obviously
fast fast is really nice.
And then the more complex Ms get into
more complex tests. Like for instance,
the Inferno Env is like a two-hour long
challenge
with a bunch of waves. And it's going to
be really useful for testing state set
based methods.
I'm at the point of needing to swap
stuff out. So, what stops you from doing
it?
Edit the code. You see the diff.
You say, "Okay, I definitely need I need
this to be a flag." So, I just have
different put it behind a freaking
condition.
I don't know. Look at the way that I've
done some of the stuff in Puffer 4.
People
always tend to over complicate it though
more than under complicate it.
I have a pretty strong bias towards
that.
Terraform cloud set.
No, it's it's a literal terraforming end
vault.
It's actually really sweet. We were
trying to get um some contracts and
construction because Spencer's done
construction stuff. So, we like we
decided to do this thing.
Where's the dozer?
Why is the dozer being stupid when I go
to load the demo, man?
I know it's a smart dozer.
There it is.
Watch it like fill up these patches.
It goes and deposits dirt and squares.
It's a pretty sweet environment,
honestly.
Like, look at that. It's making um it's
making plots.
Like, come on. That's a pretty cool
lens.
you know, few thousand step episodes.
They reasonable complexity.
Looks pretty cool.
Okay. Well, Perf goes up. Perf is bad,
but Perf goes up.
That's two more environments that we
probably don't have to write freaking
custom encoders for.
Doesn't look particularly intelligent
yet, but um it's a start, right?
I imagine you don't get paid for doing
puffer. The core is all free and open
source. We build high performance
simulations for companies. So if you
like all the crazy stuff we are doing
here and you can see oh those are pretty
hard RL problems and you have one of
those internally that's running at like
500 steps per second happens more often
than you'd expect. You can pay us to
make you a really fast one that
integrates with all of Puffer's really
nice and easy tools and even to do some
of the uh core R&D and to help make the
project really work well.
How would you like to see RL used in bio
and pharma?
I like I would be happy if our stuff
helps actually make some major
breakthroughs on designing drugs or not
just drugs, right? helping us understand
fundamentally molecular interactions to
advanced medicine. I would like if we
would use it in the discovery and
construction of new materials,
heavy industry automation as well. I
think I would just in general I would
like to see this make simulation as a
tool much more powerful.
Well, the thing that we get that I get
from streaming is I get um I get a lot
of people interested in the project and
then I get people like contributing
awesome stuff to Puffer.
Plus, it's enjoyable. It's fun.
Plenty of fish in the sea. How do I tell
she was my father?
How do you figure out how to price
things so you aren't under or
overselling service?
Aren't really We're definitely way
underpricing stuff, Jess, at the moment,
but it'll go up over time as we're more
established and as we build bigger and
bigger tools. Um,
It's actually pretty funny. People think
we're overselling, not on the price, but
on what we can do. They're like, "All
right, there's no way these guys are
going to come back in um, you know, a
few weeks with this exact thing done,
but all right, you know, this is a
relatively small thing. They seem like
they're like legitimate, so maybe
they'll still build something pretty
cool. And then we just come back in a
few weeks with the exact thing that we
say and they're like, "Uh, uh, oh, okay.
I guess you can do that."
We did that for a client a couple weeks
ago. It was pretty fun.
Usually when our stuff drags a lot on
projects, it's because like the sim spec
or whatever we've agreed on actually
doesn't make sense and then they need to
revise stuff a whole bunch as we
discover problems with the um the thing
that we've been asked to build
onetime investment.
Yeah, like any contract covers uh new
boxes for sure,
but the GPUs are not a one-time
investment. You have to buy new machines
every few years.
Then there's this thing too.
Yeah. So this is the main thing that we
why we need to price stuff more vault
because we end up doing we end up
quoting for a thing and then the work it
just ends up being two to three times
the amount of work. Not because we have
underestimated how hard it's going to be
for us, but because like the stuff that
they give us is under specified and we
have to deal with a whole bunch of
additional stuff for them.
Like I got one I was working on now that
I thought that I'd actually overpriced
it and then it just ended up being three
times the amount of work because the
spec actually did not make sense as
written. and um like the spec I was
provided with and like we had to go back
and forth 10 plus times
to be fair at least it's dramatically
better paid than IT consulting thing
like I only spend about 20% % of my time
on the business stuff at the moment
for LM's hard conceptually.
No, it's really really stupidly simple.
It's just slow.
Yeah, we're going to do go chest, but
it's not selfplay. Um the the default
setup is versus a scripted opponent.
I'm just porting up a bunch of M's to
help with um Spencer was doing some of
this,
RL for LLMs is like stupid baby mode. RL
for stupid babies.
Hey Vault, you want to see uh what
self-control looks like?
Look at this.
Is almost there.
We'll get all three of these after the
release.
Can I elaborate? Yeah. So, they can't
learn a proper value function because
like it's a sequence problem, but the
action they're kind of treating tokens
as actions when they're really not. It's
basically as if they just have a
massively highdimensional action space,
but instead of that, because that
doesn't actually work, they instead have
a really long sequence problem. So, they
just can't learn a value function. And
RL without a value function is just not
a thing. Like, you can only use the
stupidest, dumbest algorithms with that.
Um, so all these new algorithmic
advancements that they're publishing,
like you can think of these as just
incredibly stupid garbage algorithms
that you would never use an RL normally,
but that's all they can have with
language models. So they're like, "Oh,
massive RL breakthrough." And it's just
the dumbest algorithm ever, but it's
good for them because like it lets them
do it at all where they couldn't do it
at all without it.
party soon. I don't even know anybody
who plays this game anymore, man. I used
to be in like a T3 maybe PVM CC. Uh I
stopped playing for like three years and
it died. I kind of just been soloing
solo playing this for a bit since I've
been back.
I honestly don't even have any any
energy to do anything remotely difficult
on it. I've kind of just been skilling
um for like an hour before bed and
listening to audiobooks.
I'm just that out of brain cells with
the release.
But it's nice because it is a game that
is actually that freaking simple and
stupid. And it's just it's nice to have
while I listen to my book.
I'm probably going to go for um like all
the buyables
possible
might be able to cook something up.
I mean to be fair like
it's probably I would say it's probably
just you need to reformulate stuff in
some ways that would mess with the way
that they have everything set up. But I
wouldn't be surprised if there's some
reasonable way to reformulate it to have
a value function.
And then I'll say congratulations. Like
you're now not you're no longer doing
stupid RL for babies. Now you're doing
actual RL. Uh you're still a million
times slower. So good luck with that.
But at least welcome to the club.
Is this an insta solve on tower climb?
That's way too good to be true, right?
friendless was all dead. Yeah,
I mean there are people that still play,
but the people who have been
consistently playing for the last three
years, like
we had some crazy crazy sweats,
you know? No, like they'd never want to
top. They'd only go with like the same
three people for just max F, max sweat
mode.
I remember there was one guy that had um
there was one guy that had a tick
counter for everyone in the party for
missed ticks and would like [ __ ] at you
if you missed too many. if like you
missed any ticks would just start
bitching at you for missing ticks.
What game are you talking about?
Runescape. Um both because we both play
it and also because we have um there's
an environment that he's working on
that's going to be really awesome for RL
that's based on it.
It's probably why I like the low poly
style of the puffer so much.
50 maps.
I'm going to push this for him.
New raid. Yeah, I saw. I haven't seen
much about it, though.
End of year would be good timing.
It's not as easy to just like jump in
and do whatever.
I have most stuff, but like I'm missing
some important things.
five 2.5 bill is really rough. I got
about five bill on mine,
but I've got Tibo Scythe ZCB
and stuff, but I don't have um
like I don't have Shadow.
I'm missing some other stuff.
There's a lot of gear you need. You
basically need like eight build gear
these days.
I don't know, Vault. Like, there's a lot
of cool stuff we could do technically,
right? Like, let's say that we before
the end of the year, we get the RL just
kicking ass on um all the RS tasks and
you know, Puffer is going well. We
probably have Puffer 5 by then. Like one
thing we could do is just have an agent
that plays that thing. That would
probably be a really cool thing to show
off. You know, within like two weeks of
the thing launching, we have a simulator
and the agent plays it.
Yeah, I don't have pl at the moment
either.
But top is not really worth it anymore,
man. Oh, there's
98 magic. Um, I don't think TOB is even
worth it anymore. The all the money
comes from the site.
Like, you basically make nothing until
you make nothing except from site
splits,
which I it's really screwed up when they
do that. I don't know. I really like um
I'm quite interested in the like the
economies of simulated worlds and stuff
like that and
I've seen a whole bunch of different
ways that like stuff's gotten messed up
with that and that's one of them.
Grab the one more. I think it'll line up
perfectly with the release
mil an hour without scythe. Yeah. And
then you spend two of that in supplies.
Same with No, it isn't. Chambers is
better on like Chambers is way better.
A lot of the drops are actually worth
something.
Selfplay game theory considered RL.
Um,
there's some game theory applications to
RL, but for the most part, like
a lot of the math heavy stuff just has
not really worked.
The things that actually work in RL are
quite simple.
You contribute to spinning up. No, I
didn't contribute to spinning up. I did
have um
Okay, that no longer uh that no longer
said faults.
Zuck is shooting at me from inside the
wall.
Yeah, that's funny.
Did you just like spawn him every wave?
Must be different assets.
H,
that's a little irritating.
I mean, I know that they they have them
though because you can just like
It can totally learn this, right?
This thing is so freaking laggy as well
and difficult to deal with.
I think my bow is on. No, it's on a
rapid
I'm not going to do the entire thing.
Obviously,
the thing is, if id actually clicked it
correctly, it would have been dead to
blowpipe specs anyways most of the time.
So, whatever, right?
It's very very difficult to do that with
no F keys and with tiny UI.
But that is the challenge that uh Vault
is implementing.
No, that's not my game. But Vault is
making a version of that for um
Vault is making a a version of that
Okay, let's look at um what other ends
need porting.
I think the drone end needs to be ported
and everything else is okay. Oh yeah,
drive. Let's fix drive real quick.
I think we have a PR for it.
Finding C
That looks good.
Binding.H
deleted. Good. Drone C.
Drone.h.
Drone li render.
They mess with anything else.
Okay, I think this is correct.
Yes.
Wait. Numb actions plus H.
Yeah, I'll ask him about this, but that
should be non-destructive because that's
only the continuous path.
Well, actually,
16.5 mil SPS.
Great.
When do you start on uh puffers? Like
what? Two twoish years now.
Yeah,
it's been going well.
Upper is good.
Okay, so this looks bad that uh Square
does not train. So I've definitely broke
that. We'll merge Finn's PR now.
coding assistance. I mean, you're seeing
this is flawed, but I really hate this
thing. Um,
the work I'm doing now is very very
easy. Like
basically this the same exact thing
needs to be done for a bunch of
environments.
I generally am much happier when I'm
using these things less and doing more
manually and getting deeper into stuff.
We're close to release though and it's
just a bunch of small fixes at this
point and I'm like completely out of
brain capacity.
So, you're going to see me using this a
little bit.
This is zero score.
Well, no. Zero PF.
Oh, no. Now it's going up
very low.
merged.
You vault you sent me.
Okay, it's doing Jads. Wait, is that
single Jad? Wait, no, that's
I can't see.
It's getting smoked is what it's doing.
I think I got shadowbanned on YouTube
for saying [ __ ]
That's so messed up cuz I don't even
have any filters set up. That's just
YouTube's being
It's doing Zuck. That's the first set.
Oh, I'm blind. Hang on.
That was quick.
Oh, wait.
So, our agent has not learned that there
is a shield basically is what you're
saying.
The shield only protects I forget if
it's three tiles back or five tiles
back.
I think it's three.
It's also nowhere near it. So,
Okay, so this actually works. So the
drone is just something's broke.
Duck is hiding in the rock.
Oh, so you can't hit him.
I see. There are two shields
and he's over. Yeah, cuz the it's
supposed to break. This rock wall is
supposed to break.
It's probably a graphical bug. You can
probably still click him.
full ancestral and full misori.
All right, I guess that works. And pegs.
H
I remember I had a really weird setup
for my cape. I think I had I had like
Msori
and then
I think I had like
I think I had full Justy with eternal
boots and an arcane spirit shield and a
Kodai. And I think that I figured out
that there was a magic break point
around there where like you needed the
eternal boots but you would have good
freeze accuracy and you could still get
the justice set effect. It was something
weird like that.
Obviously, we can just grab the speedrun
setup when we want to do that,
but just is kind of cool. It could just
like do the Justy flick.
Try drive. Do we have any more PRs for
drive
crystal bow? That is awful.
See, the problem with doing poverty
capes is that you spend more in freaking
supplies than if you had the expensive
gear.
is bofa better DPS on rangers than
blowpipe.
I know I know that there was something
to crystal.
Well, probably not with Msori anymore,
but I think I did mine in No, I did mine
in Armadill. I think it was before Msori
was a thing.
magnate immediately and be about to say
at 50 mil. Yeah. So, Jess, that's one of
the things that makes sweeping neural
MMO really hard is uh if you sweep
neural MMO and you get something that's
good after five or 10 bill, it's not
necessarily better.
Except Jad and Zuck than both
and Jad you would use T-Bo anyways if
you had one.
Well, that sucks.
drive.
Very good driving.
Why don't we merge this first and ask
questions later?
I know that this was clawed and this is
[ __ ]
I honestly I just hate the way that the
gate is.
So bad, man.
I mean, we can try the default nets and
stuff, right?
This doesn't work.
Bay.
That's funny.
Well, this is not really learning super
well now, is it?
We'll try the default net.
I mean, look, Highway Nets is a Schmid
Hoover paper and Highway Nets makes
puffer 4 work. Without Highway Nets,
Puffer 4 doesn't work.
Yeah, that did not [ __ ] work one bit.
So that sucked.
That [ __ ] red folk.
says, "You're on a drive policy." Is
that on purpose?
I just merged in the latest PR Spencer.
Uh the policy options only get used from
Python anyways.
We got to document that.
Okay, so this [ __ ] doesn't get cold
anyways.
If we can just delete this
config ignores. No, it's used for uh the
Python version, right? So if you I think
you can specify we have to test this but
you should be able to specify different
network architectures in the uh the
Python back end but we only have the one
mining architecture in CUDA and I don't
think we it's worth maintaining multiple
nets for um CUDA min is just better
with Python it's like no code anyways so
whatever sure
it was working on one map before I I
think uh this PR
broke something. I'm looking here.
No, it doesn't jump to the Python
version, Spencer. So, if you run it with
D-Slowly, which is the torch version,
and you've compiled it for that, then
the torch version looks at that stuff.
Otherwise, like the architecture is
always just mining group in the native
version.
We'll have to document it. Speaking of
which, after I do this end, uh I can do
snake and then docks if I have some
Yeah.
Well, something broke.
Well, that'll do. It didn't set freaking
num agents.
Or it did. Wait, doesn't it set num
agents
Yeah, trains. Look at that. D.
Come on.
Oh, do we not actually train?
That looked better.
Not an amazing policy, but it trains.
Not stable either, but it trains.
Press the drive.
Fixed it.
Why is it so unstable, man? Like
end training is unstable.
That's funny.
That's pretty funny.
This one's really freaking good.
He just doesn't get it yet, does he?
Wait, what? Why is start learning all of
a sudden?
Hang on. Is it learning stuff?
Oh, it is learning stuff.
See, this is what why you just scroll
Twitter and don't actually do things
because then occasionally your runs will
just start working randomly. Okay.
Duck where he's meant to be and shield
mechanics are good. Build obs for Zuck
and see how it learns. Awesome.
Very good.
runs
666M. That sounds about right.
We're going to do this baseline and
we're going to try this and we're going
to see
that's what we're going to do.
this is working here. It's just um
not amazing.
I do wonder if sorting is going to help.
might not be too difficult to do that
and try.
I'm just going to let it do this and
straight compare
is what I'm going to do.
And then this will be the only other
experiment we run. If this is better, we
keep it. If not, we don't.
And we'll do the five minutes each,
whatever these experiments are. And then
I'm done with this.
Which college did you get in?
Uh Stanford undergrad MIT for PhD.
I also got into CMU for PhD. Uh I didn't
apply anywhere else for undergrad
because I got in early.
full of emerald. Can I try to see if we
can say just beat say two towns at once?
You can definitely beat two towns at
once. Um, so the original Pokemon Red
beat the first gym and then
I think it's harder in Pokemon Red
because you have to get through Mount
Moon to get to the second gym. So, I
think to be fair, you do have to
backtrack to get to the second gym in
Emerald, but it's not as bad of a
backtrack.
Two towns is easy. Two towns, like
that'll just insta solve. It'll be like,
"Okay, what next?
Okay, it's slower
expected.
See if this is better. And if not, we'll
just revert all the day.
I am curious to see if that is better.
That'd be a nice data point for us as
well.
This is so funny that this is Wait, is
this actually an April 1st?
They're making fun of like this is
actually how we do our [ __ ]
well, this is not like instantly solving
stuff like I was hoping.
We'll see how this goes.
Working on drive. Is there anything to
do? So, it seems like it's just harder
with
some number of maps that is bigger than
one, but is not um like 10,000. From
what I can tell, it doesn't seem like
anything else is broken. I got it up to
like 23%
by making it not repeat the same maps
across all what is it, four or eight
buffers. you get four or eight times as
many maps. Um, I'm trying something real
quick where I just sort the observations
by their distance to the uh agent.
Uh, I don't think that's going to work,
but I figured I'd just try it real
quick. And if not, I will just push this
up and we can sweep this as is
full radius.
Is that like
I can do that. Is that legitimate though
or is it
That just makes the task really easy,
doesn't it?
I can try it here. Let me
give this a few minutes because this
might end up doing something and if not
then yeah I'll do that. That's legit.
Okay.
It's kind of the reward structure for
drive is kind of odd to be fair. Like
we could probably mess with it and make
it a lot easier.
Learn goal reaching. I tested this code
version with one map and it works just
fine.
I think it is strictly just the multiple
maps and it is doing non-trivial
learning now. So it's not like it's just
doing nothing.
The road points are loosely sorted. Oh,
well, okay then. That's why, right? You
did the spiral thing, right? Yeah. Okay.
You did the spiral thing. So, this is
just going to slow.
Let's just delete this garbage that I
just did.
Okay.
Yeah. So, that's not going to help.
Then, what's the Where's the goal
radius?
Uh, I don't see it. Where is it?
Oh jeez, it's hardcoded all over the
place.
And it's here as well.
I am all for inlining stuff, but I'm not
for inlining
the same constant in several places.
That is no way. No.
Ah, okay. Good. I'll merge that then.
Why didn't I see that before?
Okay. So, here is the goal distance
thing changed.
I think we probably need to do something
with the um like the bite encoders.
You know, probably one of the easiest
ways for us to do just do floats as obs
would be um
if we just like have an encoder where if
it's a bite tensor, we just divide by
255,
you know? is you can just like scale
your floats into the range of a bite and
then that would actually be 4x bandwidth
reduction for free for a lot of ends.
Uh yes, that actually helps a lot.
We are now at 464. Yeah, so that
actually helps a lot. So it's probably
just crappy curriculum with the um the
small number of maps.
So, I can push this and we can sweep
this, I suppose.
It's not super stable,
but that should be good enough to sweep.
Got other Ms to do as well.
Yeah, I think the M speed and then the
OB sizes, we can definitely this thing
to be something reasonable.
Where's the other PR? I'll go double
check that real quick.
Uh, I do not see another PR unless this
is two days ago, right? That's max
stuff.
Oh yeah, I just found this exact same
thing.
Holy
your vault.
That's some code you got there. My god,
that's pretty freaking.
I mean, this is going to be awesome,
though.
Man just commits the entire size of
puffer lib.
Whatever shall I do if it opens sources
buffer.
Well, perf is better. Um, I'm hoping
this is at least sweepable.
Hey, what's with the spawn immunity time
from a re uh removal? Is that just not a
thing anymore?
Cuz I saw that and I had to tweak that.
Change min distance to gold to five.
That was never used.
And this is clean PR that doesn't screw
with anything else.
Clean PRs that don't screw with anything
else get insted.
Okay. Yeah. So, this was the other
change I had. Um, this was so that you
don't reuse the same environments across
every buffer and you instead get a
unique set
RS environments.
Yeah. No, the RSMs are going to be a ton
of code.
Galaxy mining game
be fun.
Well, this seems like it runs
reasonably.
wait to see if this actually finishes
and then um
go for
This is an actual update to the game,
isn't it? They like actually make the
April Fool's updates, don't they?
It Yeah, it actually exists. That's
hilarious.
And that's so funny that they actually
like make more cool stuff every year on
April Fools than they do in the entire
year.
It's above the perf that I had before.
Um,
it's above the perf that I had before
this for sure.
Uh, there are different number 722Ns
might be okay. Oh, yeah. I forgot I had
different hypers for mine. I didn't use
your hypers.
I think this is good enough to sweep
though. We can sweep from here. No need
to spend all day manually
manually doing uh runs like it's
free puffer era.
If this sweep doesn't work. Yeah. So,
we're not going to have
we're going to have machines free for
more sweeps in like a day or two, I
think. I mean, this will be one of the
M's that we use for sure. I also I
ported over today. I mean, it really
wasn't that much work, let's be real,
but
I ported over
drive. Yeah, drive works. Boba, uh,
Terraform, Tower Climb, all work and
snake.
We got a whole bunch more M's.
And we got uh I don't know, we got like
another eight hours on the neural MMO
one trail run.
Be cool.
I mean, there's no reason. They're
completely independent, but yeah,
there's no reason you couldn't make some
sort of fun demo
some RL thing in VR.
All right.
Um,
it's 4:45. I've got an hour 15 left.
Do we start on docks?
The thing is, if I don't start on docks
now, I'm not going to have the energy
after dinner to do it.
No flicker equals one.
Why did they put it behind an end
variable? The shutters.
right,
let's do um
let's start on this. I'm going to use a
restroom real quick. I'm going to get a
quick bench set in and then we will
we will uh docks, I guess.
How do you make one of these for your
GitHub?
Okay. Well, we're definitely going to
change
Um,
I actually don't know what I should do
on the sites with authorship with the
whole freaking list.
crash out a fusion. Yeah,
funny.
We have a whole bunch of contributors to
add here.
Spencer now goes up
because he's kicking ass.
and I got a bunch of other people to add
here.
You literally just have to make
something and then remind me to add you.
Pokemon Red. Yes,
it is Dr. Rubenstein.
Sir,
don't follow me, mister.
HTML then say
well it's easy Okay.
Somebody's going to have to help me test
all this crap too much here.
But I'm going to get it like partially
done.
Uh, aiming for Monday. Jess, don't hold
me to it.
Yeah, we just get to delete half of this
[ __ ] don't we?
we no longer have these.
So,
Do I want to do file by file or do I
want to do um
or do I want to go through like the
concepts and stuff?
Oh, it's almost 6. So, it's about time
for dinner. I will uh continue this
after dinner, folks.
Plug on my camera. Um,
I'll keep writing for a couple minutes,
but uh for folks watching puffer.ai, all
the things, star of the puffer on
GitHub, it helps me out. Discord, all
that. Uh, do star the puffer. It really
does help.
And actually, you know, you guys are
going to have to tell me what you want
in the docks, frankly.
web de moving.
Yeah, I don't understand that either,
Anish is like
modern web is just like stupid.
There's nothing else for it. It's just
stupid.
But we can make the pretty websites that
don't [ __ ] load.
No matter how fast the chips get, they
always manage to make them just barely
tolerable in latency.
Is what's the laziest we can possibly
be? And the funny thing is you can be
really lazy and make fast stuff. It's
just the tools themselves get lazy. I
don't know.
Yeah, but the thing is like
listening to music and playing chess on
a website like you should you should not
even need 500 megs of RAM for that my
guy.
You know,
you should basically be able to plug
something into a potato clock, you know,
or a potato battery, whatever that is.
Just plug a CPU into that and you should
just be able to have that work.
Okay, maybe not quite a potato clock,
but like you get the point. You need
basically nothing to do that.
10 hours of dev [ __ ] around
accomplish almost nothing with various
dumb things. Fix rendering. That's kind
of how it happens when you're learning
though, Weston.
I'm about to call it as well for uh for
now. I think I will stream after this.
I'm just going to be writing docs. Um if
you all have ideas for what the hell I
should write docs on, like tell me
because otherwise they're not getting
written. But don't tell me now. Tell me
after dinner.
I was going to do the overview here
that's like the design of Puffer
and then you'll have to tell me what
else.
Rocket launch
is cool, but I don't really watch them.
Couldn't count to 80.
Jeez.
Well, Weston, like why is your workflow
so [ __ ] that you're editing the wrong
file and not noticing it? That's the
that's the real question, right?
Like everybody does edits the wrong
file, but your process should be such
that you notice that [ __ ] like
immediately.
Hell, I do that still sometimes, but I
notice it pretty damn quick, right?
presentation.
Present the puffer.
The puffer.
Presenting the puffer.